- [Kelly] Have a seat!
- Hi guys!
- [Kelly] Hi! Oh I like your shoes!
- Oh, thank you very much.
I try and be fashion forward.
- [Kelly] Those are Nikes? Those are cool!
I've never seen those.
- [Jamie] Well now see
I'm middle-aged now,
I've got five kids.
I used to be young. It was great Hailee.
- [Kelly] I'm 39. I'm middle,
Is that middle aged? Right?
- I'm 46, you know?
- [Kelly] Oh? Who cares?
- But I'm still, I'm still going!
- [Kelly] Yeah! You're, you're getting,
You're getting your closing
on Harry Potter, dude.
You're killing it! (laughs)
- Yep.
- [Kelly] Well meet Hailee.
She just, she just started
loving baking by the way.
- Thank you.
- So you live in the UK.
So is coming here like your first trip
since like Covid?
- [Jamie] I'm so excited to be back.
- [Kelly] Oh good!
- And I've been blessed.
I never thought I'd be able to work in
another country or America.
So I used to come over a
couple of times a year.
Love it!
Love the variation of cities,
and the food, and the culture.
But yeah, two years of going nowhere.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I'm literally biting to get out.
So yeah, it's good!
- Biting to get out.
You're a chef. That's clever.
- Absolutely!
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] So you have,
you have a beautiful family.
And we both have kids named River.
Yours is a son, right?
- Yes!
- [Kelly] Yeah, mine's a girl.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] What are your other kid's names?
Oh my gosh!
- [Jamie] Yeah, he's very cute.
- [Kelly] Adorable pumpkin patch alert.
- Don't fall for it.
He's like, he gives me the
most grief when I cook food.
- [Hailee] Oh no!
- [Kelly] So does my River.
- He just says "I hate
it! I hate it! Ahh!"
And then when he puts it in his mouth,
then he sort of comes around.
But it's like,
a five-year-old shouldn't
make me feel so bad.
But then, but then he builds me up.
Anyway, so anyway, I've got five kids,
Poppy, Daisy, Petal,
and then Buddy,
and then that's River.
So they're all quite floral.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I was gonna
say, someone's into flowers.
- And that's my wife that
makes up all the names.
I have no, nothing to do with it.
I get told at the end.
Actually the papers
normally find out before I
know what my children's names are.
- But you're the, you
just said the first names.
I have seen your children's names.
- [Jamie] Well, you're
gonna have to quote it,
'cause I can't even remember.
- [Kelly] No, I'm just
saying your kid's, no they're
they're full on.
I am interested to know if
your wife likes weed. (laughs)
- Yeah. No, no.
- [Kelly] Because when
I read your kids' names,
I was like, this chick,
she was, she got real
high and she was like,
this is an amazing name.
Like they're great!
They're so thought out!
- I can remember River's.
So it's River Rocket Dallas Blue Oliver.
- [Hailee] That's his? That's one name.
That's one person?
- [Kelly] No that's what I'm saying!
- [Jamie] Look, I don't know!
I just married her!
I have nothing to, I can't.
- It's amazing!
I want to hang out with
her, from these names alone.
- [Hailee] Wait, can you
say it one more time?
- River Rocket Dallas Blue Oliver.
- [Hailee] River Rocket Dallas Blue.
- [Kelly] Yeah, well I like
the Dallas 'cause I'm Texan.
- But I think my wife has got a thing
about American Cowboys.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
(audience cheers)
- And many years ago, yeah!
Yeah, well clearly.
- (Kelly laughs)
- I filmed in Arizona a while
back and I was able to get
kitted out properly and
I sent her a picture.
And I think it's the only
time I had a really good,
naughty email back saying, "mhmm!"
- Ah, yeah! (laughs)
- Number six!
- [Kelly] (laughs) I love it!
- [Hailee] Oh my God.
- Anyway, I had the chaps and everything,
I went and full home.
Chaps, boots, the little
dinkely things that spin.
- Spurs.
- Which I use as,
- [Hailee] Spurs.
- Yep. Spurs.
I use it as a pasta cutter.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, you're
reminding me of a movie.
I don't know if you've seen it.
City Slickers?
- [Jamie] Yes.
- With Billy Crystal?
- Yep.
- That's who you're
reminding me of that movie.
It's amazing.
Well, your house is incredible!
This is not a lie,
I literally just told
my executive producer.
I was reading about you and I,
look, I saw this and I was like,
oh my gosh, I want to build a house.
- Do you want to come around for dinner?
- [Kelly] Look at your house!
Like, so you've been renovating it?
- [Jamie] Yeah, it's a bit different now.
- [Kelly] You inspired me.
Last night. I started just,
I want to build a house.
And I want to make it look old like that.
- Look, it's like a thousand years old.
It's very old!
- [Kelly] I know!
That's what I'm saying, it's beautiful!
- I try to, because Harry
Potter is the only person
that's sold more books than me,
I thought I'd go and get Hogwarts.
- [Kelly] Exactly. Exactly.
- [Jamie] And you know,
do some dinner parties.
- [Kelly] Build a moat
with some boats, yeah.
- Exactly, there actually is a moat.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- There is a moat!
- [Kelly] Shut up! I want
to come to your house.
- You can! It's an open house.
- Oh my, I hear that's what you're trying
to do through, right? You and you're wife?
I heard that y'all were trying to like,
almost make it open to
the public eventually?
- [Jamie] A part of it, yeah.
We want to build a
restaurant, and a bakery,
and a cookery school.
And yeah.
(Audience cheers)
- That's so cool!
- Yeah, well I mean, it's,
it's not that glamorous, right?
It's, you'd have to be mad
to buy something like that.
- [Kelly] It's beautiful!
- And you have,
I think for the people
that do try and keep these
places going, you've got
to have jobs for them.
And I feel like I work for it.
Like I don't own it. It owns me, so.
- [Kelly] Anything,
anything old, you're always
kind of redoing it.
- Yeah, but I think it's
really important to give
buildings like that purpose and,
and I want people to come
through it and experience it.
So growing, cooking, baking, pickling,
smoking, proper hippie stuff.
Come see me!
- [Kelly] I love it!
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] We get the hippy
thing with the names.
So my thing is, I love
too, it's so English,
it reminds me of like Jane Austin novels,
when people used to go
tour other people's houses,
like in the novels.
I just think it's the coolest idea,
and I really want you to
open this just so I can come.
- You are welcome.
- And we will, we will work
together, and write a song there
and it will be the greatest song ever.
- [Jamie] We have a recording
studio there as well.
- You're not, do you really?
- Honestly, if you ever
want to come record stuff,
- You have a recording studio there?
- Yeah!
- Oh my Gosh! I was just
being funny about us going,
I was just kidding.
- It's happening now!
- No, no! Just come,
- [Kelly] That's very
Robbie Williams of you.
- Today.
No, but I will give you better food.
- [Kelly] Okay! (laughs)
- [Jamie] Literally, you
can be sitting there.
I've got the workflow going,
get your lyrics going.
Look at the flowers,
I'll come in with canapes.
It's going to be great!
- [Hailee] I mean, let's go!